As a computer scientist, you have almost
surely written a computer program that,
when you run it,
just sits there spinning its wheels.
You don't know whether the program
is just taking a long time, or
you have made some mistake in the code
and the program is in an infinite loop.
You might have wondered why
nobody put a check in a compiler.
That would test the code to see
whether it would stop or loop forever.
The compiler doesn't have such
a check because it can't be done.
It's not that the programmer's
not smart enough or
the computer's not fast enough.
It is simply impossible to
check arbitrary computer code
to determine whether or
not it will halt.
The best it can do is simulate
the program to know when it halts.
But if it doesn't halt, you can never
be sure if it will halt in the future.
In this lesson, we'll prove
this amazing fact, and beyond.
Not only can you not tell
whether a computer halts, but
you can't determine virtually anything
about the output of a computer.
We build up to those results,
starting with a tool we've seen from
our first lecture, diagonalization.